i think gollum's the worst character and
also like i love them
i can't hear your answers either
hey friends we are the cast of peacocks
girls finance
and our lip reading skills are about to
be put to the test alexa volume none
we're gonna be asked questions and have
to try to answer them while wearing
noise cancelling headphones
no it goes i'm not in the music
business i got into raya
god
i am probably
planning on taking a vacation
five years oh i know this one instagram
i got a google image alert cereal
antibacterial ointment i mean probably
los angeles and nachos
caramel
leonardo dicaprio purple david cassidy i
learned to cross the street as a as a
young child because i needed to know how
to take the challenge myself do you
understand that's like a metaphor for
life why did renee cross the road it's
not only to get to the other side it's
to learn how to walk
infrared saunas
wellness i don't believe in guilty
pleasures i mean i couldn't even begin i
have a partner now so i don't i don't
really have to do that by myself
something special something special
guilty pleasure oh it's a pleasure what
is my pleasure
dogs and food
[Music]
my astrological sign is capricorn and i
think i got that one right what was it
what was it sagittarius a ford probe
1989.
i bought it new
capricorn was my answer
this is a real friday night banger
catholic i like them both i'm a morning
person now is that right
i'm gonna learn math
what's my relationship what's my
nationality what's my race
margaritas and beaches she's the same as
me
italy
my favorite rocky road what favorite
flavor i mean i'm from los angeles city
so i'm used to no seasons at all my
favorite season in new york has been
fall
oh season fall
city
um i don't know if that's what it was
the greatest city in the world new york
unpeeled hard-boiled eggs over medium
fried medium how do you like your steak
your egg what how do you like your egg
oh straight across her ears
okay
i fully cheat at games i'm sorry rene
how do you think we did i feel like i
don't know i think we we nailed it 100
yeah we did it we nailed it
[Music]
you